what's up gq this is trax and today
we're going to be breaking down the
biggest pieces in migos jewelry
collection
[Music]
first and foremost migos not only did
they spend millions of dollars
on jewelry but they also brought
millions upon probably
hundreds of millions of dollars into the
jewelry business so the biggest trends
that these guys brought
into the game that really made a
difference is they brought monster-sized
custom pieces
back to the forefront they made jewelers
they broke jewelers they made the scene
and uh you know they changed the game so
the first thing i see with these guys is
that they're loaded up with cubans
more cubans than a lot of jewelers have
in their shop
some of these cubans are ranging from 50
000 to 100 000 they got the baguette
ones
they got the two row they got the three
row they got the rose gold they got the
white gold
they got them on the wrist they got them
with the diamond lock they got him with
the basic lock
every time in every city they hit it
looks like they buy a cuban so quavo
obviously he's proud of that baguette
grill that he's got
he's got diamond glasses on he's got big
pointers in his ears but he's pointing
at his grill
that's what he loves the new trend in
the diamond uh industry is these
beautiful
new baguette cut diamonds right there's
the old style baguette cut diamonds that
they were using before
and then there's a new style and the
thing about baguette cuts they're kind
of like emerald cuts
except they are pure rectangles they
don't have cut corners that means that
you could stack them like bricks
that means that you could stack them in
a grill and have a beautiful facade
and what's the point of jewelry right is
to have something other people
don't have everybody spent all their
money on a pave flower set grill
guess what they ran out of money but you
didn't neither did uh
cuevo and he got himself a baguette
grill and when everybody gets
one of those he's probably gonna get
something different so when you're
wearing
uh millions of dollars of jewelry and
you have a cast you gotta ice it out he
definitely got it matching for whatever
event he's going to
and uh you know i think he did a pretty
good job because when you look at this
image
the first thing you do is you look at
the cast you don't even look at the
millions of dollars of jewelry
and the cast probably cost 20 000 bucks
or so
so the first thing my eye kind of
gravitates towards after the cubans
is the crash bandicoot pendant they got
this a while ago
right this was kind of in their earlier
days and it's more of a cartoony piece
all the video games that these guys
played when they were young
and then you grow up and you've got
millions of dollars and you get a
monster iced out piece
this piece right here came from inspired
by the crash bandicoot
game the aku boudica mass
and i'm a 90s baby so i do a lot of 90s
so in the crash bandicoot pendant you
got yellows you got blues you got greens
you got different color stones in there
and how does that affect the price well
it could diminish the price if uh the
quality of the stones
is cheaper right sometimes jewelers want
to take a shortcut well you could take a
brown diamond
radiate it and it might turn uh blue or
green
and it'll be dark but because it's
already changed the color it doesn't
matter so you're taking cheaper diamonds
and converting them into colors
but not for quavo okay
he has uh bright colors there the
jeweler that made that piece did not cut
corners it definitely didn't diminish
the value uh
that is in that piece the classiest
setup over here to me
is with offset he plays loud on his neck
with a monstrous amount of cubans
and then he's got big pointers two of
them on there
it's loud but it's not too loud right
aside from the pointers what's the most
expensive piece you see
well it's the one that has absolutely no
diamonds it's the skeleton
ap frosted white gold what is a frosted
ap
audemars they basically hammer white
gold
into a certain type of finish that looks
like it's frozen outside
that watch is a collectible watch no two
frosted aps are the same it's all done
by hand
right now 150 to 200 thousand dollars
for that timepiece
so the first thing in this image that my
eyes pay attention to
is the rig flare piece that offset is
wearing right it was in the video it's
the iconic image of ric flair
in his uh heyday prime time right and
then under that right next to it is the
cross
with pink diamonds in the center
offset's rings
are a collection of rings that he saw
the corner of his eye and bought and
pulled out of his uh jewelry collection
and put on that day that's what it looks
like to me
some of them might be even free gifts
from the jewelers
that they get when they spend a million
dollars i don't know
quavo on the other hand he is uh doing
something quite different
he's got all of his crazy diamond rings
on
i got it from like the old like old dope
boys from the 80s had a
they're like the one ring hole for four
hand but
i wanted to move all my fingers so
that's why i got it like
individually he's got massive amounts of
cubans and his wrist is cubaned out as
well
these guys have a jewelry store right
there
in this image as they usually do
so takeoff is taken off like elon musk
in this one right he's got the solar
system he's got the planets he's got the
shuttle and the astronaut there that's
that's a dope piece and when that hit
the internet
it really it really made a statement
that set up right there
to get done with all those carrots all
that ice at least a half a million bucks
to make that happen right uh all the
custom work all the chains and the fully
ice so on and so forth
so when you're out there guys uh rappers
artists whoever you want to look like
offset you want to look like takeoff you
want to look like quavo
you have to make sure you have a million
to two million dollars to spend just on
jewelry to compete with these guys
you have one record you did this you
have a half a million dollars in the
bank
that's not gonna cut it guys so take off
you know sometimes he's flying through
the solar system sometimes he's keeping
it mellow
he's got a cuban and then he's got an
infinity link that links into an eye
on a day like this you know you wake up
and you say i just want to wear a cuban
but i don't want to just wear a cuban
i want to have a little something i want
to have an eye the mind's eye
or whatever it might be whatever it
symbolizes to him he's got it
i think it's a it's a nice touch for
somebody who wants to be a little more
artistic
than just have an iced out cuban when
you're a superstar you can't just have a
nice style cuban
it has to have something going on this
is the bando it's the bando emoji
so here offset is wearing the trap house
piece
these are the pieces that when they hit
the internet right
they went viral the trap house it opens
there's someone shooting in the
from the back and so on and so forth now
these pieces
as a jeweler are not the hardest thing
in the world to make
it's more or less a diamond gingerbread
house but on the other hand
the effect that it had when you're
spending 250 000 to 500
000 on you know along with the chain or
what have you
on a custom piece that no one's ever
seen in those materials
and then it hits the internet and then
the next rapper that's really what
happened
has to compete it's really an investment
in their image and it works
don't think that these guys are fools
spending millions of dollars on jewelry
so here offset is got a really another
important piece for the jewelry industry
the picture piece
and these are great pieces so the trend
with picture pendant started
over the course of two to three years
ago right i don't
quite remember exactly which rapper
started it i know that meek mill
really made a scene on that but this
particular picture pendant really i like
big pointers no games no jokes keep it
simple
big diamonds vs you know what else can
you ask for
so when it comes to picture pendants
there's two ways of doing it that
depending how much time you have
right you could laser print the image
right onto the gold
uh surface and then put a clear coat on
top that's a great way of doing it or
you can kind of glue a picture in there
that already has a clear coat on it
that's kind of a faster
or a cheaper way of doing it it can be
done overnight which way is the better
one
obviously lasering it onto the gold
that's what it seems to be over here is
the better way of doing it
you think this guy's gonna have uh the
worser way or the better way of course
he's gonna have the better way of doing
it
so every time cuevo has the baguette
grill he has to point to it
what else does he have on well he's got
a big rock in his ear i'll tell you that
much and that
is quite expensive because that looks
like between three to four carats
and i know he's not wearing any sis or
anything like that
and when you're looking at those numbers
you're a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand dollar range
you have a monster pointer chain right
over
the cuban that's holding the that way
piece you're looking at
at least a hundred to two hundred
thousand dollars on that one and then
above that is a chain that looks
something like this
okay so this is a baguette
chain and what's the price of this chain
well i charge
32 000 for this chain now when it comes
to that one he might have paid more and
it might be a more valuable chain
because i can't exactly see
how the baguettes are set up but you get
what you pay for
and these are uh you know trendy chains
the pinky ring on the other hand
is a beautiful piece right that is uh
big baguettes going down the center and
round stones all around
that is a beautiful pinky ring the price
range
should be around 20 to 30 000 on a piece
like that
[Music]
so this is the classic superstar setup
that's in this image right here
so the most expensive pendant out of
this collection is the qc but the most
iconic is the that way because you're
taking something
like subway which is a five dollar
sandwich
and you're changing it into that way and
you're spending
hundreds and thousands of dollars on it
that's really where that fire comes from
right you're taking uh you know
a cartoon character that you used to
watch as a kid on cable for free
you grow up you spend two hundred
thousand dollars on it he used to
i don't know work at subway or eat at
subway whatever it might be
but he wanted to say that way and and it
works and it hits
and everybody knows that so that's
really the piece
so this is a really dope setup in it of
itself why
because the three pieces and there might
be a fourth hidden somewhere i'm not
sure but the three pieces
are layered one on top of each other at
the bottom
you got the crash bandicoot which is the
classic he still loves it
likely he wore it that day because he
want to have this monster-sized ice
cream cone
around his neck right and then on top of
that you have the schmurder schmigo
gang fully iced round stones this is not
baguettes this is not
you know the baguette stuff it'll take
sometimes a month to make or so on and
so forth these guys were moving around
he said i need this piece fast get it
done fast
got the 3d model had it iced out got it
around his neck
uh monstrous amounts of carrots thousand
percent migo on top of that
what is he saying you decipher it for
yourself i think i hear what he's saying
to me right he's a thousand percent
schmurder migo gang crash bandicoot
diamonds cubans pointers millions so the
chain
setup over here is really ridiculous
okay
it's really something to be you know
sadly jealous of i mean it's a lot of
chains
and the two monster size pointers in two
tones right you got two different colors
of gold there big rocks 50 pointers
you're looking at uh 200 000 300 000
for the setup there on just those two
chains and then you got monster cubans
behind it
one bigger than the next this is the
best of the best
[Music]
takeoff is wearing the jesus piece on a
monster pointer chain
now the jesus piece is not what these
guys started out wearing
they were making these customs they were
doing all these crazy stuff but this
he brought it back to the classic to the
biggie smalls the tupac era right
uh the i styled cuban jesus pieces
with h classes blind your broke asses
like biggie used to say
in this particular instance that classic
jesus piece got big rocks
in the in the crown right and it's got
big rocks around the neck
i really like that piece i would love to
make it for my shop
um and to me it it really does look
beautiful it has that depth
of the of the jesus face that i love
[Music]
so this piece right with quavo right
here
is uh one of my favorites personally
it's got the 3d models
of the migo gang and of course it has
the iconic beautiful
baguette cut stones that are on the
background i mean this is a
you know a beautiful piece he doesn't
stop this guy
why would he stop he set the trends in
the jewelry game and he's setting him
again
his pieces are wearing other pieces on
them right these guys are wearing chains
and the beautiful touch on this pendant
right here is
again the fully iced sunglasses on one
the lenses are iced
the grill is iced on that one and these
other guys don't have the grill
he took an image of them and brought it
to life with all the details and the
fully iced glasses is another trend
i attribute to them i don't know who
really started it but i i'd probably say
it was them
because they are on top of it they might
pull out their their keys to their uh
garage
door that might have ice on it too i
don't know they're not stopping
anywhere with the ice so the three of
them are not enameled
you could enamel that you could hand
paint that you could do all that and
they were probably
even thinking of doing all that but they
left it raw gold because he saw it he's
like leave it that way that's what i'm
imagining in my head how do i know
it's satin finish you need to satin
finish it
so the paint would stick to the
gold and it looked like he showed it to
him and he said it's ready for enamel
leave it just like that i want it just
like that i want it now i want it
tomorrow
i'm picking it up or you're flying it in
whatever it is so this
chain again i mean i could almost hear
cueva on the phone speaking to eliante
or whoever
and telling him that he wants something
that's gonna uh
you know pull out all the stops it's an
infinity link it's a new type of link
you know you can't just
pop up in the morning and come up with a
link right it takes a little time a
little thinking how are you gonna
execute that
these links are held together by other
links that are made with baguettes going
all the way around
you want to set that correct you don't
want the stones falling out this was a
special project for him
he wasn't playing around with this one
and he did it again
as a jeweler as a fan i can't take my
eyes off the picture
i doubt that i would be able to take my
eyes off the actual piece another piece
that really makes me
turn green right like yoda sitting on
top of him
so let's say you're a rapper an artist
or just some dreamer
and you wanna look like these guys what
is it gonna take
well it's gonna take some more artistic
sense right let's leave the dollars
aside for a second
pieces like that way the trap house the
solar system you got to come up with
that you can't copy that
a lot of people try to copy that they
don't hit the mark but you know let's
say you're a creative guy you've got all
these ideas and you love them so on and
so
forth better get your money up how much
money do you have to have to spend 10
million
on jewelry at least 50 million after
that when you're spending that type of
money on jewelry
you gotta have the right jewelers these
guys had business relationships with
some jewelers they weren't happy they
cut them off
there's a lot of people out there they
go to ice box eliante maybe they'll go
to pristine maybe they won't but i'm
personally going to say thank you to
them
because they brought attention to the
industry they gave a lot of business in
the game
and they set a standard by uh you know
putting their foot down and
and and doing what they want to do and
not what someone else is thinking